well
[Music]
hello how are you greetings sali jaramillo
with the most outstanding headlines of the
day vaccination efforts continue in
the state of nevada the state remains in
the first echelon of distribution and this
includes workers in the public health sector
and first aid and those
people hospitalized in medical centers
that provide long-term care,
it was also announced that they will extend the
vaccines in the first level to people
over 65 years of age, but the dates for
this have not been disclosed and new
information about the group of
essential workers battling with
the coronavirus in an investigation it was
revealed that 121 workers at the
local airport were infected with
the coronavirus since the
pandemic began the last positive test that
was registered was only this past
Saturday for its part
mccain airport affirms that all employees of
the  security and transportation agency
are required to wear protective
masks  before and visual protection
they want me is the tenth airport with the
most cases of cornea virus in the entire
country and the increase in tests for corona
virus
increased after the end of the year holidays
according to the director of the state agency
dedicated to the fight against the
spread  of the coronavirus said that if
you attended New
Year's Eve festivities where a crowd of people gathered, you
should understand yourself. He also
added that to date
a new variant of the
coronavirus has not been detected in the state of Nevada a
group of people who requested  Their
unemployment benefits went to the
Dire offices on Monday to claim the
freezing of their bank accounts.
After weeks of reporting alleged fraud
with the Bank of America, they arrived at the
dealer offices to demand that
their accounts be reopened. The
unemployment office responded that the  Applicants
must present their identification in order
to verify and be able to reopen their
accounts, a process that may take time
Between five to seven days, despite this,
several people say that their accounts
are still frozen and without access to
them, on his part, Dívar assures that he is
working to solve the problem with
the Bank of America. Now we turn to the
forecast.
The weather is expected to be a sunny day.  With
temperatures above normal,
more clouds and breezes are approaching. Have a
good day. I am I left my jara and this was
Kirchner in Spanish
[Music]